do you see it like a benefit to teaching
entrepreneurship or you know some kind
of skill set within a physics department
um I've seen it at a lot of places in a
generally like has not worked well so
why is yeah why why are you negative
attitude yeah so so my my three
biggest predictors for entrepreneurial
success are grit bias to action American
uh ability to kind of tell narrative so
grit is perseverance through failure
which many scientists actually do have
because most of the work you're doing is
iterating uh continuing to kind of
develop even after something fails
um bias to action is a little different
where so much of of
um you know depending on kind of what
science we're talking about uh you're
doing careful planning you don't get to
do careful planning when you're building
a startup or a growth stage business you
have to have a biased act I always tell
people the absolute index of bias to
action is the movie Groundhog Day by the
way happy grounding yeah happy groundhog
because yeah yeah so you get to you get
to basically live the same if you could
live the same day a million times in a
day you could make that day perfect
um and that's what a startup is you
don't know what path is going to get you
to the other side of the mountain and
you have to get over there before you
run out of food and water and so you've
got to constantly be looking realizing
you're wrong turning around going back
realizing you're wrong turning around
going back the faster you can do that
the more of a bias you have to
responding to what the environment or
the market or your product development
cycle is telling you the more likely you
are to succeed before you run out of
capital or time
um and then narrative the person who
indexes infinitely on narrative
um so so let me just say each one of
these three categories you can index
infinitely on if you index infinitely on
grit it means you will never give up
you're out of water you're out of food
you're out of money and you convince
everyone to keep going and not and not
um and you know 300 movies of the movie
300 yeah exactly exactly that's the
absolute absolute unbiased action is the
movie is the movie Groundhog Day and the
absolute on narrative is a guy like Elon
Musk uh who could show up tell you he's
gonna do something and then not do it
and still get you to give him more money
and do it over and over again for 10
years and then finally he delivers a
product but the ability that he has and
Steve Jobs had is this ability to
storytell people about what's possible
in the future and the power of narrative
is that you can attract employees to
come and help you build get in that
scrum with you on the Rugby field
you can attract Capital investors will
keep giving you money so you actually
have more time to get there and ability
to attract customers sell them on the
vision and the dream of what you're
building and um those three skill sets
are independent skill sets of and I'm
not saying that there's no overlap there
can certainly be overlapped with
scientists that are working in Academia
but I'm saying those are the skill sets
that that predict entrepreneurial
success and there's a real question on
how much of that comes learned through
behavior and experience how much of it
is it mate and how much of it can be
taught
um and that's where I think there's a
challenge of like let me just throw up
an entrepreneurship school and teach
people how to be entrepreneurs I think
that these the these things that are
necessary for entrepreneurship all the
rest of it's tactical it's textbook
stuff it's like do this write this plan
you know you know find your customer
like there's a lot of people that help
and support entrepreneurship and
development but without those three
things they're having a strong index on
some set of those three things I think
um you know the probability of success
is generally very low yeah
um and so that's why I think these
things are really hard to kind of find
yeah they're hard to find and then
there's also the kind of um you know
check your own kind of uh Sun cost
fallacies and biases too because
everything you described described you
know the systematic you know behavior of
someone like Elizabeth Holmes right I
mean good Storyteller lots of grit hard
work uh bias to action you know
influential customer seeking
um and you couldn't get like I said a
better story uh and that that brings me
to my you know I was going to ask you
you know kind of another frivolous
question but but I'd like to know you
know kind of um in terms of in terms of
how you systematize your ray dalio is
famous he has a quote a good
entrepreneur in his case he's saying
should have many things that he
systematizes or she systematizes very
well and I wanted to ask you
um you know what things in your strategy
in your investment strategy or the way
your thought process is do you
strategize in the mold of that famous
black turtleneck wearing entrepreneur
inventor Elizabeth Holmes uh so are
there things you know do you have like a
routine do you have a daily routine do
you have you know uh are you monitoring
things how do you system what what do
you systematize and what's your rubric
for systemization if you will
of the work I do yeah the work you do
and also I'd be interested in your
personal you know habits if you want to
share them my challenge is probably one
of
um orientation towards creativity so I
bias towards creativity so if I'm not
feeling like I'm endeavoring into a New
York into a new space like I have almost
like an interest or an addiction for new
things for a new space
um you know maybe there's this
intellectual curiosity problem that
drives me to do that but it's it's
coupled with this idea that I have to
make stuff or enable the making of stuff
too
um and so that makes it hard to have
um although someone did once tell me who
actually wrote a book on the psychology
of creativity that um having a system
for creativity can actually enable more
creativity than having the absence where
a lot of people want to kind of have the
absence of having a framework having a
um painting size right those are
constraints the constraint model yeah
yeah so look I mean my world is fairly
um I mean if I were to kind of try and
classify it I've got companies that I'm
an investor in or that I helped start
that I'm
stakes and companies that I'm involved
in
and
um they have different need States and
they are very Dynamic and as their need
States kind of
increase I need to spend more time with
them and that that's why it's it's not
as easy as just every week I check in
with each one sometimes I don't need to
spend time with them sometimes there's a
crisis and I gotta spend all week with
one of them and then the work I can help
them do is either recruiting or raising
capital or product and strategy and
customer stuff
um and so that's kind of spending time
with with companies then the other one
is making sure that I have adequate
Capital to do the work I want to do so
you know we raise capital from other
investors and we use that Capital to
um to support the work we're doing and
then the third is the most interesting
which is kind of exploration of New
Opportunities an exploration of New
Opportunities is all about thesis
development so um
I tell people like our job is to connect
the dots uh where we spend time reading
uh papers or meeting with Scientists or
academics or researchers or engineers
then we separately spend time with
interesting Executives or entrepreneurs
and we separately spend time in the
markets understanding the markets the
businesses that are operating in these
markets very deeply and then if we can
see a connection like if you took this
engineering capability in this
scientific discovery and you put them
together with this team you could change
that market in that way and that's the
kind of connections that we try and make
which is what are we seeing the
connections between that other people
maybe aren't seeing and that then forms
the basis of a thesis that thesis can
then go be tested or invested against
um and so we would then deploy Capital
into an existing team because they map
to our thesis uh and then they can go
and kind of test it or they're executing
well against the thesis and we want to
support them and fund them or we can
help kind of build a team and start a
company to go execute against that
thesis so that's kind of
um how I would classify how I spend my
time
[Music]